live time las vegas headliner of the
year frankie moreno is bringing his high
energy live show all the hits to the
palms casino resort beginning friday
july 29th and he joins us now it's good
to see you buddy good to be here man you
look good uh well i hate being in front
of these pictures look at this guy back
here too as well that guy looks way
better than me
five-time las vegas headliner of the
year how does that feel
i mean it's better than four-time right
yeah five times we're still trying to
get for six though you'll do what you do
with a new residency at the palms right
right exactly no it's great it's i mean
we're excited to be whoops oh did we
might be we're excited to be playing
again it's your first time on tv
we're so good
you're nervous that's right i feel like
i haven't done like the pr for a show in
forever well this is big news because
the palms is under new ownership and
they called you first to do the first
residency how does that feel it's
awesome and the room we're playing has
not had a live band
do a residency there ever which room
it's it's called chaos
k-a-o-s and uh it was a nightclub and
now we've turned it into the showroom
kind of deal
and um it's it's kind of badass because
can i say that yeah we just did it's
okay all right sorry we're live huh yeah
we're live um you know it's great
because like it's um
it's a totally different vibe than
anything else we've done but it's it's
set like old vegas we got the boost we
got the whole thing
but um
modern technology yeah your shows
they're full of energy but you started
performing as a young child what 10
years old on star search i did that yeah
i i did some research and i think i
think we have
on star shirts 10 years old let's take a
look at this
[Music]
how old are you in this this is with ed
mcmahon this is back in the day he said
i was 11 yeah that aired after my
birthday but i was 10. you're 10 years
old yeah and i learned how to sing just
for the show i know how to play piano
and they're like we don't have a
thing for piano you have to learn how to
sing so i learned how to sing got on the
show first time i've ever been on an
airplane
vomited peanuts through my nose on the
airplane did did you win
no i didn't win you didn't beat you no
and i couldn't he was standing right
there with the check i could have just
knocked out and mcmahon take the check
and go some i don't know what that guy's
doing now i don't know but but what
happened is i did that show and the
phone started ringing like can you come
do this i was doing all the motion
picture guild stuff in l.a for all the
big you know the oscars and stuff i'd be
playing all these after parties and
it just led uh
a long road of never stopping that
appearance on star search has led you to
this moment right now with me on las
vegas that's right exactly appreciate it
frankie the show starts up a week from
tonight right from tonight 8 p.m and
ticketmaster has all the tickets
beautiful thank you you've put on quite
the show buddy thank you appreciate it
thanks for having me frankie moreno with
special limited engagement starting or
featuring all the hits starts july 29th
chaos at palms tickets go to
ticketmaster.com